the bay area i won't
now peter bergen author of holy war
incorporated and terrorism analyst for
cnn during this forum hosted by the
close-up foundation he discussed his
book about the world of osama bin laden
mr bergen is one of the few western
journalists who have interviewed bin
laden the event is about an hour
hello and welcome to the museum in
arlington virginia for this week's
close-up at the newseum discussion hi
i'm john moleski of the close-up
foundation today we're going to be
discussing a book by peter bergen that
book is called holy war incorporated
secondary title inside the secret world
of osama bin laden let me introduce you
to peter bergen peter is cnn's terrorism
analyst and is the author of the book
and he uh is one of the handful of
western journalists who have ever
interviewed osama bin laden face to face
and in the course of his reporting he
has interviewed scores of insiders from
al qaeda also included in that list of
interviewers family members of the bin
laden clan taliban members and cia
officials
let me ask you this peter how long were
you working on this book and those
interviews before it was published i
started writing it two years ago um i
resigned from my job at cnn to write the
book but i've been reporting about bin
laden since 1997
uh in a fairly intensive way but also
interested in afghanistan
really since i was
at university i made a documentary about
the afghan refugees flowing into
pakistan and that was in 1983 so i've
been interested in afghanistan and
pakistan for quite a long time how did
how does terrorism specifically become
your beat in essence well it wasn't
something that i uh necessarily ever
thought would be my beat um
basically with the bombing of the world
trade center in 1993
uh it was clear that some of the people
who had bombed the world trade center
had trained in afghanistan and so we
trained we went to afghanistan to really
just sort of sort that out and try and
find out how the bombing of the trade
center uh was planned and you know
increasingly it looks like it was a
dress rehearsal for the events of
september 11th in the sense that ramsay
yusef who was the mastermind of that
bombing trained in a bin laden camp
um and also was associated with bin
laden after the bombing certainly with
his followers when you when you talk
about dress rehearsal how how literally
do you mean that in other words was that
just the warm-up act or did they think
at that time more damage could have been
done with the munitions they used well
ramsay youssef the mastermind uh
famously told an fbi agent when he was
brought back to new york in 1995 the fbi
agent pointed out the window at the
trade center and he said look they're
still standing and ramsay yousef said if
i had had more more money
more explosives they'd be uh collapsed
and obviously the al-qaeda group
did have eventually more time more money
although they didn't bring it down with
explosives they effectively turn planes
into into missiles do you think they
believe that they would get the result
that they got with the use of the
aircraft that the towers would actually
implode upon themselves
well it's hard to know what they believe
but um bin laden there is a tape which
may
be airing the airing as we definitely
imminently in which bin laden says that
he was surprised how effective the
attacks were he says that he expected
only the top portions of the tower to
collapse not the whole building to
collapse the reason the building's
collapsed my understanding is is not the
impact but the fact that um you know the
the heat that was created inside was so
intense that it literally melted the
steel girders the building and
apparently the steel um lasted about as
long as it was predicted it would about
an hour yeah i mean it's one of the
things that's striking to me
uh you know 50 000 people work in those
buildings and there are a lot of
visitors how i mean there was still a
huge death toll but uh we were lucky
that it wasn't 10 000 people the death
toll now appears to be about three
thousand yeah as that number goes down
it really speaks to the effectiveness of
the evacuation yes
the now you mentioned that uh
this had somewhat been flagged by what
happened in 93 in the comments
afterwards
then we hear a report that hosni mubarak
provided a warning
about 12 days before the attacks that
something was brewing as according to an
egyptian newspaper report but were we
asleep at the switch i guess that's
where i'm headed with this question
there seems to be evidence that
if we had taken this more seriously
perhaps we could have been in a higher
state of alert
well there were indications in the
summer of this year that something bin
laden's followers were definitely
planning something because um a number
of them were arrested in yemen near the
american embassy with plans to blow up
the embassy perhaps
a number a couple of guys were found in
new delhi in in the indian capital
planning to blow up the visa section of
the u.s embassy a very busy visa section
there was also a videotape made by bin
laden's group which indicated to me i
was able to download it on real player
format it was fairly widely available on
the internet
and on that tape bin laden called for
additional anti-american attacks
so it's certainly clear to people who
follow bin laden's organization whether
they're journalists might like myself or
u.s government officials
uh who actually issued a very strongly
uh worded alert about perhaps imminent
attacks against americans in the arabian
peninsula
in july uh they issued that it will
alert but the thing is everybody was
looking at the wrong place
and you know it's very easy to kind of
second guess everybody after the event i
mean i think it's indisputable that this
was the worst failure of intelligence
american intelligence in history it's
just you can't argue with that statement
on the other hand in the defense of the
people that uh were gathering that
intelligence bin laden's people who came
here to do this attack were extremely
well disciplined they didn't brag about
what they were doing to their friends
they didn't boast about it they didn't
get arrested for the kind of petty
infractions that might get them deported
um and they're obviously very serious
and very committed so it's uh
uh it's it's hard to sort of really
point the finger but the fact is that
eventually there'll be congressional
investigations which we'll look into how
did this happen because uh presumably i
mean there are all sorts of uh safety
measures that have been taking place but
nonetheless it would be very
useful
to get to the bottom of how could this
have happened the the world you've been
living in and the people you've been
talking to
your sense of how great the threat might
have been before september 11th
was it at the level of the september
11th attacks the sheer audacity and
effectiveness of those attacks
on september 10th the the the kind of
threat that bin laden represented uh was
fairly large he was uh he was he had the
unprecedented five million dollar reward
on his head he was on the ten ten most
wanted list for the fbi
um you know he bombed you american
embassies in africa bombed an american
warship in yemen last year it was these
kinds of threats uh not the kind of i
mean which were pretty serious i mean
the 200 africans died in the embassy
attacks 12 americans
uh in the attack in yemen against the
warship 17 american sailors were killed
so these were significant threats but
they weren't the major national security
concern facing the country which is what
it became on september 11th what is your
sense right now of the ongoing threat
we've had now three official warnings
from the u.s government this
administration about the potential for
new attacks what is your sense of where
we stand right now
well i think the the the third alert
referenced religious holidays and uh
this group has tried to attack american
tag targets at the end of ramadan the
period we're in right now uh they also
tried to attack uh in the christmas and
new year's
season
this was all in the course of there was
a plot basically to attack los angeles
international airport
uh tourist sites in jordan and an
american warship in yemen right around
the new millennium so obviously this
third alert i think is a very reasonable
alert
of course where those attacks might take
place to what extent al qaeda is still
in business uh remains to be seen
tell us the circumstances of how you
came to meet face-to-face with mr milan
um in 1996 the united states state
department put out a rather detailed uh
white paper it's called about bin laden
which actually laid out a lot of
information about him that he was the
principal financier of islamic extremism
in the world that he had training camps
in afghanistan and sudan as a result of
that i asked my bosses at cnn uh if we
could try and set up an interview with
him i met with his contact in london uh
the correspondent peter arnett and
myself traveled to pakistan and then
afghanistan to meet with him
um you know it was it was a complex
operation they're very concerned about
the security of bin laden even in 97
even for just a television interview
they were concerned that we might be
kind of
secreting some kind of tracking device
that would give away giveaways location
so it was it was it was quite a
performance to go and meet him uh but
he's given interviews to other
journalists he also gave an interview a
year later to abc news um which was a
very interesting interview because in
our in the interview that he gave us
he said that uh he was targeting
american soldiers and if american
civilians sort of got in the way that
was their problem
but uh by 98 he was saying we make no
distinction between uh military and
civilian targets which obviously he
doesn't
what give us a sense of the i you know
i'm gonna ask i'm not asking you to be
melodramatic but
in just the type of work that you do
give us a sense of your own
uh sense of personal risk when you're in
these situations we're going through
these james bond-like scenarios to go to
the secret place where you'll interview
bin laden you know there's a memorial
out here to journalists who've died in
the you know the line of fire in action
and we've had more journalists die in
the current activity in afghanistan what
is your sense personally of your risk
well you know i mean i think it's a very
interesting point you know eight
journalists have died uh in the course
of this war and more journalists and
soldiers right so it's a very dangerous
war particularly for journalists um
because the situation there is very
fluid
um
my sense of personal risk going to meet
bin laden i wasn't worried at all after
all he'd invited us to come he's not
gonna
sort of mess with uh with the point of
the dude was to do an interview and and
rather than being you know frightened i
was actually you know i was pleased that
the interview happened and
uh but certainly the notion uh you know
i i've only been in a kind of war
situation once and it was quite quite
worrisome obviously but um you know some
people go all the time and uh you know
they they risk their lives on a routine
basis
uh what what is most understood a
misunderstood i'm sorry about mr bin
laden based on your research
well there's some misunderstandings that
uh about his personal life that there
were reports that he was sort of
womanizing and drinking in beirut when
he was a teenager
those reports apparently are wrong
um you know the reports that somehow the
cia may have funded or trained bin laden
and his followers um
that that is a wrong as far as i can
tell i i have a chapter in my book which
examines that proposition the cia had
only six officers in in in pakistan
during the afghanistan war against the
soviet union they were awfully busy if
they were doing all the things they're
supposed to have been doing the cia
funded afghan factions but bin laden has
a lot of his own money he was very
anti-american why did he why would he
need american money why would he since
he's anti-american from an early age why
would he be meeting with cia officials
it sort of defies common sense plus
let's do the thought experiment where
there was a cia official who was really
bin laden's
as it were a trainer um you know
that person has a 20 million dollar book
contract you know to explain
how that happened i mean it justifies
logic uh that uh bin laden would be uh
uh consorting with the cia he's denied
it american officials have denied it
what about some of the broad
breaststroke characterizations madman
fanatic evil mastermind any of these
applies yeah it's too easy to just i
mean just calling him crazy the outcomes
of his actions are obviously insane but
he's certainly not psychotic in any kind
of clinical sense i mean he's he's an
intelligent man he has a sort of set of
rational beliefs
the outcome of those beliefs is not
rational i mean his political views are
not exceptional in the middle east you
know a lot of people don't like american
policies in the middle east but a very
only tiny minority prepared to do
violence against americans as a result
but i think you know just dismissing him
as a madman
it doesn't really help anybody
particularly the victims because
it um
you know we have to try and understand
you know how this happened and just
saying he's crazy i don't think helps it
doesn't help understanding of how these
things develop
you mentioned earlier that if al qaeda
is still in business is i think the
phrase you used what is your sense of
al-qaeda as an organization how
widespread how organized how likely that
it can still
operate without this state cover that
was provided by afghanistan and the
taliban i think you know afghanistan was
a very particular moment and bin laden
was a very particular moment without you
know bin laden's group is sort of
somewhere between a cult and a mass
movement in a way and you know when cult
leaders die their movements go very
quickly with them jim jones david koresh
obviously this is more of an occult um
but you know bin laden it looks like
he'll be captured or killed imminently
and and the first thing about he may act
as a martyr for his group um
but you know the first thing about
martyrs the most obvious thing you say
about them is they're dead and somebody
you know how how
how can you you know he won't be able to
run the operation he and his top
leadership won't be able to run it and
the training camps in afghanistan were
key to this exercise because one thing
to sort of dislike the west but it's
another
uh to go to afghanistan hook up with a
group like al qaeda we can teach you all
sorts of skills like how to manufacture
your own explosives or run the cell so
it doesn't get penetrated gives you the
ideology and the training to turn you
somebody who does maybe doesn't like the
west into somebody who can do a lot of
damage and you know al qaeda the
president himself has said that al-qaeda
exists in 60 countries but in a lot of a
lot of those countries it's small
potatoes i mean there are probably
we've seen a lot of arrests in europe
it's it's certainly possible that there
are a number of people still
out there in europe perhaps in the
united states i mean there's also been a
lot of arrests here but um it's very
hard to tell how many people are still
active and what they might still be
planning but this group has shown a lot
of patience in the past so it would not
be impossible to think that
some attack has been in the planning for
some time
um you know they spent five years
planning the embassy bombing attacks in
africa
so and they also do very unexpected
things like no one expected a embassies
in africa to be attacked no one expected
the u.s warship to be attacked
so given the fact that they are patient
and they do unexpected things it's
certainly not impossible to think that
there's another attack in the pipeline
that may have been in the pipeline for
some time
well we have students with us today from
richard montgomery high school in
rockville and we're going to turn to
them now for questions and comments yes
sir you're first i'm kevin robinson from
only maryland uh mr burgeon in the wake
of the september 11th attacks there have
been several cautionary procedures which
have been adopted by the united states
government and other governments across
the nation across the world
which of these
do you believe these precautionary
procedures this heightened state of
security will exist around the world
forever or how long do you believe that
this
will take place
it's hard to tell but it's difficult to
imagine that you know that you go back
to the same situation at an airport that
prevails on september 10th where
essentially you wasn't that serious a
check of your baggage
um you know you go to an airport now
there's national guardsmen armed i think
that situation will continue you know
for the foreseeable future it seems the
only sensible thing to do
kevin have you encountered any increased
security in your daily routine
well um at certain places such as fort
meade there have been heightened levels
of security
and
even going into dc in uh the first few
days of the september attacks you
couldn't even get in with that uh type
of military id yeah what about uh in
school anything going on in your school
um we are now issued id cards throughout
the entire school and there is a
more strict policy on lunch and leaving
for lunch to go off campus
picture id cards uh yes
and that's since september 11th they
didn't exist before then
we had a lunch id which was only
necessary for going off campus but now
it is required for us to keep
our id cards on us at all times
including at other schools such as short
high school you actually have to wear
the id
thanks
hi
hi
i'm maggie hanifal from tacoma park
maryland and i was wondering how do you
think the release of the osama bin laden
videotape will affect the opinion held
by the american public of the war
now we have the time travel issue here
in that we are taping this program on a
day when that video is imminently to be
released so
you're in the position of prognosticator
here by the time people see this
discussion on c-span uh that polls may
be showing what the reaction is
well i mean given what we know these are
the statements that bin laden makes on
this on these tapes on this tape um you
know obviously
he seems to take a high degree of
responsibility for the events of
september 11th so
um i think that the tape will speak for
itself in a sense
it sorry
the tape will speak for itself in a
sense in the sense that
you know bin laden seems to take quite a
lot of glee in the attacks on september
11th i don't think that will help his
cause certainly in the united states or
indeed anywhere in the muslim world
do you think there will be any uh
significant negative backlash from this
tape in the muslim world i would guess
so i mean i think there's been a
backlash against bin laden as a result
of the events of september 11th you know
bernard enjoyed quite a lot of
popularity
uh up until september 11th uh but one
thing that struck me is we're not seeing
demonstrations of you know hundreds of
thousands of people out in the street
saying what a great guy he is because
you know unprovoked assaults and murders
of thousands of civilians i mean there's
nothing in islam that can you can use
islam can't there's no language in islam
to defend these kinds of actions so i
think bin laden overreached and he hoped
to provoke some sort of clash of
civilizations it turned out to be a dud
the people who are going to kill or
capture bin laden are overwhelmingly
muslim they're the afghans on the ground
going after him as we speak so the holy
war incorporated it's that's from his
perspective you don't think that he's
managed to create a holy war
well he's he's tried but it um but i
think it's it's failed i mean muslims
around the world haven't rallied to his
cause the middle eastern governments are
enthusiastically cooperating against al
qaeda and in afghanistan the people who
will actually take down al-qaeda are
overwhelmingly muslim
thanks hi
i'm tara howard from olney maryland
um mr bergen do you think bin laden or
the al qaeda organization at all
anticipated the outpouring of support
for the united states that occurred
after the images of the collapsing world
trade towers went on to on the air
it's hard to know what they anticipated
but i think i think they did anticipate
that this event would somehow be the the
spark of some wider war against the
the west and and it didn't work i mean
and i think you're right to talk about
outpourings of support i mean there is
there isn't a government in the world
that isn't cooperating in some way
uh with the fight against bin laden
because a lot of middle eastern
governments by the way understand that
he represents a big threat to them as
well because he's interested in
installing a sort of taliban style
theocracy in every muslim country and
obviously the muslim governments aren't
you know that's not something that they
would sign on for
thank you
hi hi um i'm liz lawrence from tacoma
park maryland um questioning the uh war
that the u.s is involved in right now do
you think as a reporter
the impact of the vietnam war on
reporters and how the media coverage
changed during that is impacting how
reporters are reporting on this war in
afghanistan well they're very different
wars i mean yeah in vietnam for a start
there were american troops and hundreds
of thousands on the ground and there was
a much uh
you know reporters had more freedom of
movement during the vietnam war and the
pentagon has to some degree constrained
uh american reporters on the ground who
are reporting about american military
matters i mean if you're an american
journalist you can report anywhere you
want in afghanistan but there are
certain restrictions regarding reporting
on american military matters and that's
a decision the pentagon has made and
there's always a conflict between what
the pentagon wants and what the media
wants the media wants as much access as
possible the pentagon wants uh
a degree of secrecy uh and in every war
whether it was the gulf war this war or
the vietnam war there's always a
conflict between what the two sides want
but there is a fact that during the
vietnam war there was a lot more ability
to go with soldiers on the front line as
a reporter well do you think if the um
if the war were to expand as
our i guess this is a totally kind of a
different question um if
um
is there a foreseeable end to the war
and if not
obviously this is a further expanding
war do you think it could end up to be
similar to vietnam with negative public
opinions coming back as the war goes on
and on i don't think so i mean the war
was about the war in afghanistan is
effectively going to be over relatively
soon and after that you know there might
be pockets of you know al qaeda in
places like chechnya or somalia but it's
going to be on a totally different scale
and the public is overwhelmingly in
support of the war i mean uh the ball
had certain names which are basically
the defeat of the taliban and the
elimination of al-qaeda and those aims
are being
rather rapidly uh
you know they're coming to fruition
is there another hot spot somalia
iraq where the network has its second
most amount of training facilities or
other type things
you know just
afghanistan was an order of magnitude of
difference and iraq you know is a sort
of separate issue there's no indications
that iraq was involved in september 11th
i mean you know saddam hussein is not
the world's greatest guy and there are
other reasons i mean the united states
has been in a low-level war against iraq
since 1990
and if saddam hussein refuses to allow
weapons inspectors in uh to look at his
weapons of mass destruction um
again there will be consequences but
they are separate that's a separate
issue from september 11th forgive me if
this is an oversimplification just
trying to get
my arms around this notion is
if you were going to sort of pie-charge
the al-qaeda network and its resources
and its capacity how much of that is
gone with the loss of the taliban in
afghanistan as a home base i think a
huge amount because that was where all
the training camps were and that's where
the leadership more than 50
it's hard i mean i think it's you know
it'd be like uh taking out the corporate
headquarters of a large corporation and
then you know there are satellite
officers but you know it it's the
leadership is gone
uh and the ability to train people is
gone cut off the head the tendrils die
sort of yeah i think eventually i mean
it's a question of when but uh but
eventually it will
hi hi i'm judy wexler from bethesda
maryland and i was wondering what level
of involvement do you think the united
states should take in the coalition
government that was outlined outlined in
germany
for afghanistan after the fall of the
taliban
well you know the united states closed
its embassy in afghanistan in 1989 and
afghans feel very strongly that america
kind of abandoned them having used
afghans to help defeat the soviet union
uh it was the blood of afghans that got
the soviets to withdraw and they feel
very strongly that uh america kind of
abandoned them that's not going to
happen now i mean afghans going to
decide what their own government's going
to be but the united states first of all
is hopefully going to provide a lot of
money to the future government of
afghanistan this is a country that's
been at war continuously for 22 years
uh a devastated place it's one of the
poorest countries in the world it needs
a lot of help and the united but i don't
think the united states is one of the
reasons that you know the whole the
whole situation of rose in afghanistan
is if the united states had perhaps been
more involved and perhaps be more
supportive of the northern alliance in
the first place you could imagine a
situation where you know those training
camps and bin laden wouldn't have
actually been able to flourish in
afghanistan so i think the answer is the
united states is going to be very
involved in afghanistan not in the sense
of like deciding who the government's
going to be because that's a decision
for afghans but in the sense of giving a
lot of support what about as far as
peacekeeping troops on the ground
well there seems to be a debate about
peacekeeping troops on the ground but
the afghans assume mixed signals about
it but apparently the british may be
involved uh they may take the lead um i
think that you know it sounds like a
good idea by the end of the day you know
if the afghans can police themselves why
not let themselves please themselves if
if it's not necessary and they may there
are questions of national sovereignty
that they may feel strongly uh that they
don't want a huge
uh international force they've had too
many international forces you know
whether it's the russians or the bin
ladens already they want the kind of
their own country at back i think and
that's really the best outcome for all
of us judy what is your sense of do you
support
a u.s presence beyond a particular acute
period of warfare
well i believe that we should help them
establish a government but i don't
really support what's going on what's
going on the balkans right now i mean
if we go in and get involved in
peacekeeping tropes we might risk never
being able to get out and never being
able to let afghanistan function as its
own country so i think that it might be
necessary to send troops in at some
point but
i don't think that we should have
this go on forever and we should
recognize that afghanistan should be
self-sufficient in i think your point is
actually right you know that i mean in
the sense that if you do put
peacekeepers in they tend to stay for
much longer than you think at the outset
um and if it's not necessary you know
why why not as you say in bosnia these
you know the peacekeepers are there
they've been there for a long time um
the fact is that the peace has kept in
the balkans so the peacekeepers are
doing their job and there haven't been
you know american casualties and and you
know in a way
um you know i think that was appropriate
thing to do in bosnia it may not be the
appropriate thing to do in afghanistan i
mean we'll see i know you've written for
the times of london what do you feel is
this support uh in great britain for
british peacekeeping forces i know tony
blair has been talking about great
britain potentially taking the lead in
that area
well i think there's been high you know
pretty high degree support i mean
britain is you know going to take a
potentially leading role so
um you know i think the british uh have
been the most sympathetic to the
american viewpoint of any of the allies
hi matt adler from potomac maryland and
i was um
wondering if you could tell me the
degree to which the i mean it's well
known that there's a lot of arab news
media which is overtly anti-semitic and
anti-american and what to what degree
did that press
play into the development of bin laden's
hate for the west
and
if it did play a high degree uh what is
the role
or what should be the role of um
american middle eastern allies in
stopping
that from occurring are you are you
talking about the press uh as sort of a
megaphone for bin laden to get his views
out um well no i just mean uh in general
not necessarily um publishing his you
know or showing his videotapes um but
its articles are um beyond critical
their uh
incite inciting um and so i was just
wondering okay
well it'd be hard i don't think it's the
role of the united states government to
tell other governments what their press
should do i mean uh you know
i i agree with you as a general
proposition that there is uh
uh perhaps uh you know that there are a
lot of middle eastern papers
uh uh subscribe to a sort of rather
paranoid view of the world for instance
i mean it's not uncommon view in the
middle east that uh somehow
the attacks on the world trade center
was a jewish plot because four thousand
jews didn't show up to work i mean you
you hear this but i don't think any
sensible person believes that and um i
think there is also by the way in the in
the arabic language press whether it's
al jazeera television or or uh or some
of the independent newspapers like al
kudz i mean there's a lot of
self-examination i mean bin laden
bin laden was attacking a lot of middle
eastern regimes
and there was a lot to attack about a
lot of these regimes they're
authoritarian there
they don't respect human rights um
so i rather than blaming you've seen
this movement in certain voices in the
arab world saying instead of blaming the
united states for our problems why don't
we sort of look inwards and start really
blaming the the regimes we have around
us because i mean they're the people who
are corrupt and uh you know not letting
a free market economy flourish and these
kinds of things
thanks there's a story today that there
exists another al-jazeera interview with
osama bin laden that al-jazeera is not
releasing because they feel as if bin
laden commandeered the interview
and it makes him look bad
right it's it plays to the criticism
that perhaps he had been using al
jazeera as a mouthpiece well i think you
know for a start we lead we live in a
media age so you know bin laden's a
smart guy he's going to use the media in
the same way that you know
but i mean at the end of the day i don't
blame the media for bin laden's
activities i blame bin laden what about
the discussion here about whether or not
the tapes should be played by u.s media
outlets they know that the white house
was critical of early airings of some of
the bin laden's messages what's your
perspective on that
well my perspective is you know connolly
i connolly used to rise the national
security adviser talked to various of
the heads of news organizations and said
we're concerned about coded messages now
i have no idea what those coded messages
may be
um it's fairly obvious that there's an
uncoded message in a lot of this which
is kill americans so you know having
that sort of repeatedly
broadcast hardly seems a very good idea
um you know i think it's a general
proposition i'm a first amendment
absolutist and i think the more
information we have the better but i'm
not privy to the obviously the what the
the government feels that there's coded
messages and if that's the case then
perhaps er on the side of caution if so
you're the news president and you get
the call from condi rice what do you say
to her well i'm not lucky so i'm just
hypothetically saying
i don't know i mean you know if she's
she's the national security adviser
she's saying we're concerned that there
are coded messages i mean what are you
going to say it can be so absolute in
the first amendment that you want
at least to pause to consider whether
she she has onto something
i i i i don't want to second guess the
decisions of people who made those
decisions i mean i just i think that
one i mean one of the most useful
outcomes here
is um would be a trial of bin laden you
know because i think if you had a tr i
mean i don't think that's likely to
happen but if there was like an eichmann
trial as it were of bin laden or
something which laid out
in as much i think i'm i'm somewhat
opposed to these military tribunals i
don't understand much about them but i
my concern is anything that might be
construed as being very secret doesn't
help because if you have somebody on on
trial like let's say one of bin laden's
deputies we want to know as much as i
think the public has a right to know as
much as possible about what the plans
were what plans may be in the offing
where the where his you know we need as
much information as possible one of the
reasons that i was very concerned about
the group
before september 10th is because there
was a trial bin laden associates in
manhattan which laid out that they had
experimented with chemical weapons that
they had you know tried to acquire
nuclear bomb grade uranium
um
you know these sort of things were very
useful to have in the public domain
hi hi i'm i'm jim chung from rockville
maryland um if al jazeera the afghan
network was so anti-american why does
cnn have an alliance with them to share
information i mean my impression is
their arabic network uh my my impression
is they're not anti-american i think
that they've
i i i haven't watched a lot of albums
here so but my my you know it seems to
be uh have a lot of different voices
anti-american
uh pro-american pro taliban anti-taliban
uh it's it seems to be functioning
uh in in a very good way by the way this
is the first television channel in the
middle east that really
doesn't have a lot of government control
um
and is allowing a lot of different
voices to flourish now some of them are
anti-american that's fine i mean you're
not there's no crime of being
anti-american i mean the crime is
killing americans
why i'm interested in your your premise
why are you assuming al jazeera is an
anti-american network oh i read an
article about about the al jazeera and
um
it stated that they're uh predominantly
anti-american so you know the source of
your article i'm just i'm just i think
it was the washington post i i read the
article i mean it did lay out what
seemed to be a pattern of anti-american
but but i think you know
they've had uh they've had con yeah
they've had american officials on i mean
i think they're trying to give a broad
base if if it's predominantly
anti-american i mean so be it i mean
it's nothing i mean you can't criticize
them for necessarily uh airing different
perspectives i mean
that's the whole point of the free press
i mean there are plenty of people who
are anti-american
we're not talking about people who are
being anti-american we're talking about
people who are killing americans it's
one thing to voice anti-american
sentiments they're not uncommon um
and uh you know there are people who can
criticize america for all sorts of
reasons including people who are
american in fact it's very american to
criticize the united states that's the
best thing we can do in a sense you know
i mean it's not like everything we do is
correct
thanks
hi hi i'm han chau of germantown
maryland and i was wondering how the
arab region has been interpreting the
u.s goals in the u.s campaign in
afghanistan
well it's you know one thing is since a
lot of con it's hard to do a public
opinion poll of like uh what arab
opinion is about what's happening but i
mean i think that you can
what the thing that's interesting isn't
is what's not happening you know cairo
is a city of 15 million people we're not
seeing hundreds of thousands of people
taking the street saying it's terrible
the taliban have fallen and it's
terrible bin laden or you know in
karachi is a town of 15 million people
in pakistan same thing we're just not
seeing these big outpourings of massive
popular support so i think that
um
you know i
you know for in a sense by what we're
not seeing i think it gives you an idea
perhaps of of the level of uh you know
certainly bin laden was somebody who was
popular in in the in the middle east and
popular in pakistan but i think his
popularity took a big nosedive with the
events of september 11th because it's
not his actions aren't really defensible
on any level
the symbiotic relationship between
bin laden and the taliban that's coming
to light it seems as if neither could
have existed without the other to the
degree that they existed up through this
event
well i think belland was very critical
to the to the taliban in the sense that
he gave him money and he gave him man
and he gave them ideological kind of uh
but uh you know on the other hand you
know uh the taliban was an indigenous
movement right from kandahar and i don't
think uh
you know as a world government it seems
very isolated you just made the point
nobody is
shedding any tears over the fall of the
taliban no no no uh
and uh i mean who would because who'd
want to live under the taliban i mean
the taliban i mean i don't the taliban
weren't the worst movement in history
they've been you know the last century
shows many worse movements nonetheless
uh
they uh their their general uh
i mean they thought they were creating
paradise here on earth and that's a very
dangerous thing to think we've seen that
repeatedly in history anybody who thinks
they can create paradise here is
probably going to create in fact sort of
a mini hell for a lot of people
hi
hi my name is amy garlock and i'm from
chevy chase maryland and um i'd like to
i'm wondering
basically the us government their policy
with osama bin laden is we like to bring
him back dead or dead and when he when
he's gone
and with also the
um
the
demise of the taliban regime do you
think that there's like a significantly
less
risk of having attacks from al qaeda and
other hate groups from
like the arabic world
well i mean i think that bin laden dead
and the al qaeda leadership gone and the
training camps gone i mean
you know it will eventually that puts
them out of business i mean the only
question is are there attacks in the
pipeline which are still you know that
were planned long before september 11th
which might come and there's indications
that uh john walker the american who
joined the taliban has apparently told
investigators that there were plans for
attacks other attacks at the end of
ramadan which we're in right now
so
you know who knows i mean i you know
that all we can say is this group has
been fairly successful in the past at
attacking american targets
not they've always they've if you throw
enough darts at the dartboard one you
know some of them are going to hit not
all of their
attacks have been successful
but nonetheless i think uh you know
you'd have to be a real optimist to say
it's impossible though they won't attack
again
are there other groups sitting out there
in afghanistan or other middle eastern
countries
that have the same type of funding and
leadership and training that could
theoretically attack the united states
there's something called the armed
islamic group which is an algerian group
that has cooperated with bin laden in
the past and one of the members of that
group was planning to blow up lax
airport at the time of the new
millennium so the short answer is yes
there are other groups
but but the longer answer is those
groups are i mean they're nothing like
al qaeda they
what will happen i think is a lot of
these groups cooperated with bin laden
but uh with the without bin laden and
the top leadership um they'll kind of
revert back to their their own local
concerns they may return to attacking
people in algeria which is what the
algerian the armed islamic group in
algeria has been doing for years rather
than trying to attack americans
how important are bin laden's personal
resources to this entire network his
personal wealth
well i talked to somebody in the family
who was privy to the details of his
inheritance and he inherited 35 million
which is a fair amount of money but
money is not you can't persuade people
to fly passenger jets into large
buildings because of money so
i think that at the end of the day
that's about belief and so you know what
bin laden was able to do all of the bin
laden operations involved this is really
successful once involved people who are
willing to die
and so at the end of the day while his
resource has been somewhat important
you know it's this ability to recruit
people who are willing to die in these
operations we hear stories about him
ladling out large amounts of cash to
taliban and cars as gifts things of that
nature yeah he certainly gave
apparently he gave three million dollars
to the taliban right before they were
about to take kabul the capital in 96.
so you know i mean money's been pretty
helpful and yeah one of the things that
made him attractive to his followers is
he's a guy who could have been leading
the life of the typical
multi-millionaire palace in saudi arabia
yeah what happened child of privilege
could have led a cushy life yeah why did
he choose this path well it's hard to
tell but um he
uh i think he's
several things his dad died when he was
10 which would be a very traumatic event
for anybody
and um
i think that he may can see himself sort
of
he said that he's continuing
so in some way the legacy of his father
fighting against the enemies of islam he
said that
but also you know the invasion of the
soviet union into afghanistan in 79 he
was 22 he was a relatively young guy he
uh that was a very transforming moment
for him um it's hard to really
explain him um because uh you know i'm
suspicious of psychological explanations
of people when you don't have a huge
amount of information about him and the
fact is i mean bin laden's family is not
really talking about him
bin laden himself has not really got
into i mean he if you ask him it's
pretty simple i mean he has a political
program
based on his religious beliefs which is
get the amer get the americans out of
the middle east whether it's support for
israel whether it's america american
troops in saudi arabia arabia big states
that's his that's his sort of major
sticking point yeah
so you know he would say it's american
policies it's causing him to do this
what what about you you mentioned you
can't buy people who fly airplanes into
buildings
so we've heard about his his charismatic
abilities that you describe it as a semi
cult what was your experience one to one
with a man did you pick up on any of
that
was he a compelling figure uh you know
not particularly to me i mean he was
speaking in arabic and i don't speak
arabic so that's one thing but he wasn't
like you know bill clinton is a sort of
a personality who fills up the room
uh
bin laden is quite different when we met
with him in 97 he was almost um retiring
you know he was very soft-spoken he was
very mild-mannered he was extremely
focused
uh his words uh you know even though you
could bear that he was whispering his
words were very enraged against the
united states that was in 97 in a
videotape that was circulating earlier
this summer of bin laden um
you know i saw which we was talking to
his followers he's much more passionate
and engaged and aroused and then we've
seen yourself i mean we've seen
ourselves on october 7th we saw bin
laden
first emerge it was right in the middle
of the first american attacks against
afghanistan and the new york times
reporter uh memorably described it he
looked as untroubled as if he was as if
he was on a camping trip
and um
you know so he he has a he he he's
pretty low-key but he doesn't you know
he must have some charisma for his
followers but he doesn't seem to me to
be uh at least for my meeting at a
terribly one of those sort of huge
personalities
he um he comes across almost like a
cleric rather than a revolutionary um
and um
so you know of course in 97 we had no
idea of who he would become perhaps
there's a cultural barrier here where we
just can't get inside the head of
somebody who would find him compelling
in that manner that's possible but um
and uh yeah that's that's possible
nonetheless you know i think even you
know even across cultures are certain
people who have a huge charisma and i
don't think uh i don't think bin laden
is one of them
hi
hi um margarita litback from
gaithersburg maryland i was wondering
how do you think that the united states
media coverage uh surrounding the events
of september 11th has influenced the way
the public views osama bin laden himself
well i mean the american public
obviously doesn't like osama bin laden
uh and how the i mean i don't think that
i don't think you know if there was only
one media report about the fact that the
thousands of americans were killed in in
about an hour uh i don't think that uh i
mean so i i don't see how the media
cover
how would the media coverage
influence a negative view of bin laden
is that what you're asking well no all i
know is um before the events of
september 11th i know i wasn't
i knew that he was kind of a terrorist
and i knew he was responsible for many
acts of terrorism around the world um
targeting the united states
but
something of that magnitude really
got me mad and i know i
my i guess i felt an increasing sense of
negativity towards osama bin laden and i
was wondering do you think
that
this
the most americans feel this way and is
this mirrored throughout the world as
well do you attribute your increasing uh
anger or whatever however your
characterize it toward bin laden as a
function of the coverage or just as your
own reaction to the facts of the events
well there have been so many
dramatic reports on it i saw a reporter
herself break down on camera
interviewing families of the deceased
and
i think it the coverage itself
definitely has influenced me i think i
would react
i would be mad if i just heard that
someone had
um
flew pla flown planes into the buildings
and that they collapsed but then seeing
people jumping from them
on tv
definitely
in
uh evoked
more emotions within me well one of the
criticisms you you hear and i'm sure you
both heard it is that there's a sort of
flag waving aspect to the coverage and
there even as far as some on-air
commentators bill o'reilly comes to mind
pretty much promoting military response
early in the
in the in the
situation
what is your analysis of of this
question and as it relates to the notion
of the u.s media sort of stoking the
fires of hatred toward bin laden or
warfare well you know
uh an unprovoked attack on thousands of
civilians is a is
hard to get past that is it well and
also it's a it's a it's a very good
reason to go to war i mean what better
you know it's very hard to second-guess
the fact that there was a a very strong
military campaign well i think the media
let me just say make a general
observation i think i think it's very
easy um you know the media is the way we
get our news obviously but i think and
obviously you know it's there are
different filters different you know
left wing right wing liberals whatever
but at the end of the day you know these
events it's it's very hard to get past
the events themselves and as you say i
mean watching people throw themselves
out of the world trade center was just
devastating and um
you know i think the whole thing was
very emotionally i i was very emotional
out there who wouldn't be i mean it was
you know i was in washington like many
of you and um
you know it wasn't very clear what the
targets were and i was going to see an
end to you know cnn could have been a
target it wasn't you know there were all
these um
there were all these
uh
unconfirmed reports of perhaps a fire at
the state department or a bomb or
basically it was a real confusion about
what the what the targets were it was it
was very hard not to be emotional and
then also knowing all the deaths of all
these people so
uh you know if people found you know i
mean if you're in a very emotional
situation it's just only human i mean
after all reporters are only human so if
they have an emotional response i mean
that's that's sort of their prerogative
really
thanks thank you
hi hi my name is lindsay bernstein and
i'm from rockville maryland and i'm
aware that the footage from your
interview with
osama bin laden was edited and censored
what types of things not only in your
interview but in everyday broadcastings
in afghanistan are censored and edited
my our interview with bin laden wasn't
censored in the slightest there is a
difference between editing and censoring
no when we well first first start we put
the entire text of the interview out on
the out on the internet
and secondly um we did a 20-minute story
and we obviously used the best parts of
the interview in that 20-minute story we
didn't just broadcast what was in our
interview uh but we did put the text of
the interview on the internet so it
wasn't censored in any way and i've
never encountered any censorship in my
job
well
is it true that
you uh or the taliban used their own
equipment to
oh well
i don't know maybe i was confused about
this
in the
the bin laden folks were conf were
concerned that our
camera equipment might in some way
uh it contains some sort of tracking
device
because they're concerned about bin
laden security so they said you can't
use your camera equipment you can use
our handheld digital camera
and uh you know i wasn't that happy
about it but that was the only way we're
gonna get the interview so but i mean
that's a very different thing from
censorship
okay so
in any event what types of things are
censored in
um
in the broadcastings of afghanistan
i just think you may be
confusing censorship with editorial
judgment if peter edits his piece
nobody's telling him not to air
something which is what you're i think
suggesting with the censorship notion
well in the same article that was
mentioned before i read that
um that uh actual broadcastings were
edited and censored so i was just
wondering if that could be clarified
because by what news organization
was it a u.s uh news organization or no
it was taliban
or
the al jazeera show al jazeera yeah well
i mean you know we talked about the fact
that bin laden gave a number of
statements and and
certain news organizations chose to not
broadcast them
either because of concerns about
propaganda and also some certain
concerns about news value i mean if
milan repeated calls for attacks on
americans aren't news and and b are
potentially dangerous so
um
you know al jazeera i think apparently
has also exercised some uh restraint in
terms of the
types of they weren't i mean they're not
gonna give bin laden a platform just to
always go on and say whatever he wants
and
uh that's appropriate news judgment
that's different from a government
saying we want you to censor things um
obviously there was uh the united states
government did ask uh this whole
question of coded messages but in my
personal in my work i've never
encountered a situation where
there was censorship in the way that
you're discussing okay thanks
hi
hi i'm amanda white from gaithersburg
maryland
um bin laden's reasons for his hatred of
americans and his attack on the us are
still debated and i've read that uh your
theory on his reasons for attacking the
u.s um many people disagree with so what
exactly are those reasons and what do
you say to those people who disagree
well i mean i i don't have to i mean if
you in bin laden's statements uh they're
always the same i mean when you when
people ask him why are you calling for
attacks on americans he says it's
american policies in the middle east he
doesn't talk about kind of cultural
issues that we might he doesn't he
doesn't say it's the first amendment or
madonna or pop music or drug and alcohol
or these kind of cultural issues that
you might expect him to be
interested in he is interested as far as
he's concerned we're infidels and you
know we can do what we want with our
lives i mean he's not concerned about
how we lead our daily lives and we had a
lot of people saying it's an attack on
the american way of life of course
that's how it felt like but if we
actually look at what bin laden says
it's all about american policies in the
middle east and surely he's the best i
mean why would he
in thousands of words and statements
uh it's not like he's pretending that uh
this is the reason i mean we do i mean i
take people at face value and take bin
laden at face value you know he's
against american policies in the middle
east that's why he's doing this
so you don't think that our culture in
any way
has
sparked um more of a hatred for
americans at all in osama bin laden's
point of view
well i don't because if you look at his
statements he never mentions it you know
it just there may be people who don't
like hollywood movies uh in in the
muslim world or whatever but that bin
laden does he never mentions it maywork
is a recruiting tool in trying to get
others who feel that way about american
culture yeah but also he uh you know the
attackers came and attacked the pentagon
and the trade center which in their
minds were symbols of political military
might they didn't attack a hollywood
studio they didn't attack targets
associated with like american cultural
uh so i think it's a you know in islam
there's no distinction between the
religious and the political in some
senses and bin laden so it's been long's
religious political beliefs it's not his
concern about american cultural issues
and you know pete i can you know people
can disagree with me as much as i want
but i mean they don't have to disagree
with me this all they have to do is read
bin laden's statements they'll find out
why he's at war what is your sense of
how large the actual planned attack was
on september 11th versus the elements
that actually reach fruition
i know dick cheney said he believed
there at least another plane headed for
the capital for example yeah
well it's hard to tell i mean you know
flight 93 crashed in uh pennsylvania and
that may have been
on the way to attack the capital i don't
know i mean
we may never know obviously i mean one
one thing is that uh
if as we discover more al-qaeda
documents i mean there may be as it were
some sort of
you know the that we may actually find
out eventually what the other targets
may have been what about your sense of
the capacity uh i know a lot of people
are obviously worried about things like
smallpox or other biological and
chemical weapons bin laden himself has
made allusions to having a nuclear
capacity if america uses nukes he'd
respond with nukes
did you talk to him about any of that
and what is your sense of how much of
his bluff and how much speaks to a
potential real capacity well we you know
that time it wasn't an issue because it
wasn't clear that bin laden was
interested in the nuclear question but
the fact that he'd say we have nuclear
capabilities we'd use as a deterrent if
united states used nuclear it's a very
funny thing to say because the
likelihood of the united states using a
nuclear weapon against bin laden is zero
so why did he make that statement he
made that statement i think because he's
prepping people for the possibility that
he might use them
and uh he doesn't have an atomic weapon
in the sense of nagasaki or hiroshima
dirty bomb dirty nuclear bomb it's quite
within his he's got the money the
motivation they've made efforts to
acquire this material you know why
wouldn't he have it and he said he has
it when why i think that's very
important you know bin laden declared
war against the united states in 96
and people took that perhaps as a sort
of rhetorical flourish well he was
deadly serious about it so when he says
i have some kind of nuclear chemical
capability why ignore it
so bluffing's not part of the game
interestingly he didn't say i have a
biological component and he's surely
aware because he listens to news reports
of these anthrax things in the united
states so he took it he didn't deny he
didn't
he
all he said is i have some nuclear and
chemical capability and we know from
uh trial transcripts uh that he does
have this motivation to get nuclear and
chemical stuff and there hasn't been
evidence of biological experiments
so uh to me it was sort of interesting
that he took a pass on the biological
issue
um
and and it also it it to me reinforces
the notion that he's pretty serious
about this nuclear and chemical issue
hi
hi my name is jeremy kim and i was
wondering um how bin what was what bin
laden's role was in the um afghan war
against the soviet regime and
how that um led up to his leading of the
al-qaeda network
well i mean bernard um
bin laden and his followers who are
known as the afghan arabs you know they
came from around the world uh perhaps in
the low numbers so tens of thousands
perhaps to come and participate and that
was very important for them because they
kind of rubbed shoulders with each other
and they met each other and they got in
you know they
and that became the basis of al qaeda
their role in the afghan war
in terms of actually getting rid of the
russians was pretty limited because in
fact it was afghans who were fighting in
their hundreds of thousands
that really it was the blood of afghans
rather than bin laden's recruits but
that being said bin laden himself did
fight on the front lines against soviet
troops in 1986 in fact in a place called
chagi
which is not too far from torah where he
may be now
so bin laden did personally fight some
of his followers personally fought and
that was a very dangerous war
they showed quite a lot of courage
uh but in terms of actually getting rid
of the russians from afghanistan uh in
their own minds they felt like they
defeated a superpower but it was really
the afghans who got rid of the russians
uh not bin laden's recruits
thanks sarah hi i'm daniel belkin from
rockville maryland and with al qaeda's
situation deteriorating near tora bora
do you feel there's a somewhat
possibility that i'm a loyalist to bin
laden may turn them in take the 25
million and
um save their own hide
i mean it's possible i mean 25 million a
lot of money particularly in afghanistan
but
i think that you know there was a 5
million reward on bin laden says since
1999 and no one took advantage of that
and the people around bin laden are
volunteers they're not people motivated
by money
and uh so i think it's it didn't happen
before
so why would it happen now i mean
perhaps as an afghan villager who may uh
you know be looking to make some money
and get the reward but i think the
reward um
the reward didn't work two years ago um
and that was five million dollars which
again is a lot of money in afghanistan
so i think that the reward is unlikely
uh to yield as many results as simply uh
what's happening right now on the ground
which is afghans going after him
thanks
yes sir hi um i'm sean faye pay and i'm
from gettysburg maryland and as a member
of the press do you ever hold or
withdraw information in order to help
the war effort in the sense like does
national security ever trump the first
amendment to a free press
well you know i mean
i mean i have i've i i've rarely
reported in a in a war zone where the
united states in fact i've never
reported in a war zone where the united
states was involved i mean i've been in
a war zone but it wasn't it was in
afghanistan and it was during the civil
war there
so
you know i i haven't
you know i i think that the pentagon uh
usually is is very uh very clear with
journalists about when national security
concerns are involved i'm not a pentagon
reporter but i mean sometimes national
security concerns do i mean uh trump the
first amendment uh
you know if you're talking about the
disposition of troop movements you know
and you know it's going to be covered
live
look the columbine high school was a
very good example
you know
there were people there were live news
reports about what was going on which
the students who were killing the other
students were watching and clearly uh
the
you know first amendment rights can be
trump by you know if people are going to
be killed
um so
i have not been in a situation where
that has come up for me personally
but the fact is that sometimes national
security concerns all the concerns of
just uh you know just the the potential
murder of of of students uh because you
know the first amendment is not absolute
um it is uh it is the first amendment so
it's the most important one but
sometimes other concerns can trump it
thanks hi hi i'm jen carrick from olney
maryland and i was wondering if you
think after osama bin laden is gone
either captured and in prison or
receiving the capital punishment if
another
taliban or terrorist with anti-american
sentiments would replace it
is there an heir apparent is that what
you're asking is there someone in
waiting to fill that void well just that
uh the people are still there and they
still have their feelings towards
america and american policies and
whether or not they would just regroup
and another osama bin laden would appear
out of it
um you know there are people like lower
down the organization who who are
important but they're everybody you know
everybody knows who they are so they've
been going off going after two i think
look i mean there's going to be
terrorism against the united states just
as that's a general as a general
proposition that is the case uh there
was in the 1980s
um that's not going to go away but bin
laden and the people his immediate
lieutenants were people who've got
decades of experience of organizing
things they also had a failed nation
state with a sympathetic government
which is afghanistan which could
basically do whatever they want and i
think without those two things i think
that you know al qaeda and bin laden was
you know a pretty unusual phenomenon and
although there will be continued
terrorism against the united states it
won't be on the scale that we saw on
september 11th it'll be it'll revert to
you know perhaps
americans being kidnapped in countries
like colombia or americans being
attacked in in iran you know places in
the middle east that is not going to go
away but it's all a question of scale
and the reason we're here to talking
about this at all today is you know the
catastrophic events of september 11th
but it wasn't the first terrorist attack
against an american target nor is it
likely to be the last one it's a
question of is it something is it your
major national security concern as it is
right now or is it at the end of the day
uh
a major irritant but no more than that i
mean and as a superpower the united
states is always going to have people
who disagree with its policies um so i
think that uh that's a very long-winded
way of saying
i think that bin laden and uh you know
we're not going to see somebody like bin
laden again i don't think
thanks peter bergen thank you as well
here's the book holy war incorporated
great read available in bookstores
thanks very much for joining thank you
thank you very much thanks to you as
well i want to let you know those of you
watching on c-span that we will take a
holiday break following this program the
next two weeks will be replays of
previous programs we have one coming up
for you next week that includes foreign
journalists with their perspective on
the activity that's going on in the
world today and then following that will
be a discussion with lee hamilton and
bob dole two prominent former members of
congress about how congress works we'll
be back in january 2002 with our guests
rodney slater former secretary of
transportation and some others talking
about safety concerns trout as it
relates to travel hope you'll join us
then in the meantime for all of us at
the freedom forum the museum and the
close-up foundation i want to wish you
and your family a happy and healthy
holiday season and a safe one and i'm
john maleski thank you for watching
[Applause]